okay uh now we'll go into the standing
R and the definition that I have for a
standing Roll versus a small forward
roll is in a standing roll your knee
does not touch the
mat and you are in compliance with that
definition even if your knee is this far
off the
map and as a safety
feature uh you should always try to
lower your knee as much as possible
uh which means as much as nogas
technique allows you to do that your
better nogas aren't going to allow you
to do it at all um but you will never
through your own agency post your leg
like a ferite UK does and and make a
pull volt out of it you don't want to do
that so if nag is missing the x pattern
for example if they're missing uh the
projection Vector through your Center
you will always be able to lower your
knee to within an inch of the
mat at no point do you ever have to do a
front brakeall um as UK so if you end up
having to do a brake fall it's because
Naga captured your arm and isn't letting
you touch the mat on the negative side
of the circle meaning they were never
going to let you touch it on the
positive side of the circle and in some
way they keeping it from you touching
the negative side of the circle on the
mat so you don't have to learn back you
don't have to learn front Brak Falls you
get thrown in front brake Falls you
don't there's nothing to learn there
okay but when your arm is not captured
and whenever the projection Vector
through the center is absent you are
able to lower your knee and you should
lower it as much as
possible this reduces the chances of
injury allows you to train more often
per week allows you to train longer into
age because the higher you are off the
map the more risk of injury there is
okay all right so in drill six the
beginning of of adopting the standing
role we're going to work from what we
call be
pose and we're going to emphasize that
we are going to put our shoulder head
area in an entirely different plane than
our hips we don't want them uh going in
the in the same plane in the same
direction okay and Naga is not going to
let you do that so we start out with
this kind of posture here move a camera
where you need to so you can see it and
all you're going to do is learn to lift
one leg and the cross lateral arm and
you'll roll at an angle you will not
roll straight this way okay okay and
again you can get as low as you want
with your KN you will have accomplished
the drill does not matter so we use this
to let people get comfortable without
putting that knee on the
mat so as soon as I pick up my leg the
cross Lowel arm will reach
over and I
roll with that straight back and if I
roll at that angle
my hips and shoulders are never of the
same vertical
plane all right let's try
it e
so at this point you'll have people that
still want to touch the circle on the
the mat on the positive side of the
circle and I just filmed some clips
showing you different degrees of that
um so you can do this drill we'll call
it 6.1 where you're going to hit the
mat uh on the negative side of the
circle
okay SL slapping the mat in this fashion
makes it impossible to slide it forward
and touch the mat on the positive side
of the circle so slapping the mat calm
down is closer to what we're going to
end up with and you make people do it
this way in this drill 6.1 go for
it all right let's try it
all right the next drill we'll do from
Kam uh which again because you're going
to go on one leg
um it doesn't really matter how you
start you could start here and step out
you could just pick your leg up does not
matter how you start but what I have
found is that most beginners are nervous
about falling from what they perceived
up higher and so just by putting this
leg in the back and I'm going to allow
them to crawl out into that last stance
okay it's basically the last stance it's
just already started because the other
leg is not on the
mat and they can get as low as they want
as long as the mat the knee is not
touching the mat same thing
[Music]
all right let's
try okay this is drill 7.1 and you can
do the same thing where you make them
hit the mat because it's impossible to
hit the mat and be on the positive side
of the circle and we don't want that
okay so it'll look something like this
all right let's try it
all right so drill uh seven is that let
people hang out there as long as they
needed to be
comfortable uh that's where a lot of the
fear of heights starts to come in the
fear of falling
and uh they will not do
this body posture okay so you let them
hang out there there's a downside though
to drill six and seven uh and we had the
same downside in the small forward roll
and that is that to touch the mat to
have the security of touching the mat
you have to close off the chest and uh
it's this shoulder coming towards the
that is fighting the what's happening to
your body okay so if we look at happens
to the body
naturally uh if he goes into this
Warrior post here and he just hangs out
eventually uh his leg will swing out to
the outside everyone can do this
experiment on their own and go ahead
just use I'm going to let go using me
for balance in the meantime okay and
you'll see that the legs will want to
swing out eventually all on its own
don't touch the M okay it wants to swing
out and that's what we actually using uh
because as that leg swings as that leg
swings out his ability to keep his head
up is is reduced on any on anyone okay
and this is that effect that I posted on
the on one of the videos right that the
posture of this right angle this
three-legged right angle uh destabilizes
so much and the L flips toxy turby and
inside out okay and that's what we use
in our throwing geometry uh but as we
watch him do that and you now look at
his chest the shoulder is up the
shoulder is not down shoulder is not
down okay the shoulder is going to be up
and this leg's going to go that way and
that's where that's the role he has to
find so what we're going to do now in
drill 8 is no more uh hand rail take
that hand out of it okay uh you can do
it from as low as you want it doesn't
matter you can do it down here just let
them do it where it's comfortable but
you still have to touch the mat uh on
the negative side of the circle so I'm
coming
out all right let's try e
okay a detail on drill eight is because
of the Fear Factor you're going to see
people
breaking the relationship between the
head and the foot and they're down here
like this and even in the last drill as
I went
out I came out my foot has to come
up that that is part of this drill so
I'm not going to be here and then roll
as my head goes down my foot comes
up my foot lifting lowers my head this
knee can continue to
bend okay you you don't want to roll
from up here but you can't break and
lower like that so I'm up
here
up up
[Music]
up okay make sure that foot is not
staying on the ground right all right
here I can show you how we get
up um it follows the rule of don't give
your back to the uh to the nogget to
your opponent so hence we don't we don't
do the Donovan weight front brake ball
where he gives his back this is very
incorrect so you're going to do your
forward
roll you'll hit this
spot you're going to put your hands on
the
mat turn you're looking the other way
let all inera
out and then press up and draw back into
H me
from
standing hands on the mat open the knee
all inertia gone like a back squat
up draw into Han
[Music]
me okay let's try e
we'll have you go from that side he's
going to represent like assaultive
energy
linear Force
okay uh you're not just getting up any
old way one of the things I said is that
you could you're doing the back squat
okay uh and there's no more inertia
going that way so hold on uh we don't
use the inertia to get myself
up this is
incorrect if he had thrown me you can
push me and I use that inertia he keeps
that assault going don't get kicked
up coming in he can push me over
more this is not
good
mindset so as he had thrown me Eastward
whatever he's coming in he's he's going
to run into what in essence is your Sumo
stance so he's pushing
we're not going anywhere if he tries to
go over
it you can lift him
up when you're in on
me he can't push you
over okay
so that's what you're seeing you don't
have to do it
when here here this is
incorrect incorrect okay try
it all right uh drill nine this is the
last drill and this is how I try to ask
everyone when we say you can me at the
beginning of class to warm up this is
what I would like to see them
do um to me this is the end limit of you
working with your own self-generated
forces after this there's a huge
gap
um in making the jump from here to where
nog is actually taking you apart
head feet and Center in three different
directions okay but this simulates it as
far as the mind is concerned okay and
that's where all correct form starts so
what I'm going to do here is go up into
that 90° stance that I had Roden in my
leg will naturally swing outward and I
will let myself go off balance I don't
have to make myself go off balance
I don't have the agency of the Leaning
and the lowering I don't have any of
that I just seek that warrior pose my
leg will swing out I lose balance I
refine my organization starting with the
negative side of the circle so I kind of
in here this leg swings
out I find what I'm
doing let it swing out you're going to
have to stop let it swing be off
balance get up the same way
okay try it okay detail on this one is
you're going to see your your scared cat
UK want control of this and this is
where I I didn't take myself off balance
I I took myself to here and that leg
will spin out I didn't make the leg spin
out and you're going to see them do one
motion so as they moving forward it'll
be taken right into the roll and this
means they never lets go off balance so
to do this real correctly there's a
momentary pause
here you can get there but as you try to
stay there it'll swing your leg around
so there's a pause there it does not
look like
this that that was me controlling it not
letting me go off bounds on this one
there's a hanging out hanging out then
you let it
go then you find it so there's a pause
in that warrior pose try it again